whoa hi okay warning this game contains
spoopy content note is a quick goal okay
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to three five nights at
Freddy's fan games it's time again
because they are still being made
constantly and voraciously this is
baldies basics in nightmares I'm gonna
start off with someone that's kind of a
hybrid of two separate ideas that we all
know and sometimes love Oh God that's a
nice remix I suppose oh God
Baldy will appear either on the left
right or middle if he appears in the
middle play a sound if he appears on the
right press L what the Frick if he
appears on the left quickly go back Duty
nightmare principle if 2d nightmare
principle meter defeats completely you
will be forced into detention make sure
to keep the meter up
oh my god hey let me read this I'm not
even gonna read this out loud okay
alright so bald is a big [ __ ] the
principle is come some kind of sanity
meter you gotta press Eve for first
prize and use the safety scissors and
you got to do play time and use the
safety scissors and sweep will happen
randomly oh my god oh my god what the
[ __ ] what what oh it's so many
instructions what kind of class am I
supposed to take to try to be able to
beat this game alright so there's two
separate instruction sets you know
whatever I'm almost gonna go for it
of course okay mmm survived 300 seconds
to unlock the secret ending good luck
make sure you have visited the how to
play section for more in-game tips no
not in game tips just absolutely how to
play okay a to look at left hall has to
go back to middle extra hide tips okay
let me keep those up for just abuse Oh
what did I do
why did I do I don't know what I did
okay I guess I'm in detention now thank
you
what happened to your face what happen
to your luscious lips what happened to
your vibrant knives
okay okay I have no idea also it's too
bright in here
it's not moody enough for Baldy okay
let's try that again shall we
I'm gonna have to read the instructions
because I have no idea how to do
anything but let's try this at least one
more time before I go back to the
instructions okay there's something
about the meter okay I got to go up and
hover over the meter or something like
that weird
okay sweep sweep sweep way I don't know
where the safety scissors are oh whoa oh
hi huh well Q ah q there we go right
okay but I would wait whoa whoa whoa
whoa
[Music]
what air go back and learn how to play
this okay I got it
I got this I got this I think I got this
you ain't got nothing on me Baldy
huh you ain't got nothing on me
you ain't got nothing on any of me I
don't know where I am
Oh sound I got him I'm doing it
hey I'm doing it hey Wow hey I got him
that's going down quick sure you do
you sure do don't ya you sure do
oh I don't like you Baldy I never liked
you before but I don't like you now the
tricky ones gonna be when he appears on
the right I gotta press the L button
which is far away okay
all quiet oh no where's you where was
you at [ __ ] that's [ __ ] okay try
it again
oh hello alright so we can appear while
I'm just looking at him huh okay oh I
don't like how you just dive dive Baba I
don't like how you just dive bomb out of
the nothingness of the sky maybe it's
cuz I'm just keeping my hand over on the
meter and that's no good well oh I don't
know that did but it works
hey no Q go no no no no okay okay I'm
faster now look nope nope nope nope nope
well uh okay I guess I won and how am I
gonna survive 300 seconds of this
[ __ ]
hundo hundo baby what Oh
150 halfway there halfway there almost
now we're halfway there
yeah this is surprisingly stressful for
a really shittily made game I wouldn't
say it's even really shittily made I'd
say it's just slightly less competently
amai those clothes do you wander to
mondo coming up big - uh no big 200 for
me I'm losing out don't lose it nope no
no no no yeah no we're not no you know
no you know no that that meat is really
going down fast okay come on oh god I'm
gonna make it I think I just gotta focus
in on the task at hand
sweep sweep sweep your hello ever me 250
so close so close so close no go back
huh huh huh so close so close so close
so close so I'm going oh [ __ ] I forgot
oh oh god oh god oh god I almost forgot
no comeback good
yeah that's all there I know not now
[Music]
Thanks
wow I did it I feel so good about that I
feel real good
all right take care you have fun have a
good life
farewell that was surprisingly good that
was surprisingly good that was quite
good now this next one is probably going
to be quite bad
this one's called five nights at Blue's
Clues collection the following games
included are not intended to be serious
and our joke games but it's not call
five nights of Blue's Clues
it's called feve NEETs at Blees Cleve
needs it this equal thief needs it
please please t five five minutes at
blues country favorites it booze cruise
or feet please please we must there's a
guy at the beginning let's go to the
beginning how do I
[Music]
[Applause]
needs that you have to look at the
cameras but you don't have cameras so
you're gonna die
[Music]
what I was feeling it please let's try
few beats it please please tea
oh boy
night night night ass and I'm I'm here
to kick gum and chew ass well I can't
seem to do nothing so Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
what a masterpiece what a masterpiece is
if a guy go pretty faithful recreation
of it it's a surprisingly decent
recreation you got you gotta admit the
kids getting better the best oh this is
great that's not even close to on the
wall okay oh no oh no it's B's key it's
it's booze coos uh-oh
booze cruise
I guess well if you're hearing this um
congratulations you've beaten feet meat
Sibley's Cleese tree um I just wanted to
point this out this is a troll game I
only made this because it's like joking
by me and my friends grab it or I'll be
the Lenny large anything that's by the
way um anyway this is just an inside
joke game I hope you guys understand the
humor of it and if you read this game
one then I understand why because it's
kind of just immediately supposed to be
a parody of the fact that fan games out
there but anyway I hope I hope you guys
look forward to my neck inflator project
soon this will probably be the last game
in the series it's completely up to mark
if I either decide to make a fourth game
but the fourth game will be much
different it's not gonna be copying off
of for now it's gonna be a lot more
different anyway I'm gonna I'll be I
have to get back to work on my one of us
and then bujji's projects so thank you
guys so much for playing of what we'll
find might feed me - please please and
as always I will see you all in my next
project that I do good bye guys
that's so sweet it's less sweet now well
what about feve needs it booze coos
[ __ ] Oh God
[Music]
all right five dabs ass okay days five
days oh oh I'm moving okay I'm in hell
oh well Oh
[Music]
oh hello
well thank you thank you for my ears
exploding I appreciate that also I it's
weird cuz they're steadily getting
better at this they've got parallax
scrolling in here and they've got disco
well I'm dead I guess I'll be mute ass
here real quick thank you that's good
okay well now that I properly muted the
ass I'm eagerly awaiting the death that
is you've completed these idiotic
challenges well you know I'm an idiot so
idiotic challenges come naturally to me
did you honestly think something big was
going to happen at the very end honestly
no I expected nothing I didn't even
expect this but I appreciate it it's a
little bit of attention and everyone
knows I'm an attention [ __ ]
not really but what's going to happen
might interest you how my ears gonna
bleed I'm ready
scream at me any attention is good
attention in my eyes oh there's no see
well you know I'm not shocked uh-huh
okay what if this was made by Scott
Cawthon
wait but there's one final one
Phebe needs it please please we must
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah all of fav Nate's a please please
can't believe we got through the whole
game what a journey that was what an
emotional journey I'm so glad that that
we've that we that we did that I'm so
glad
alright see ya all right so to cap it
off this is weekend demo like a lot of
these five nights at Freddy's fan games
they are just a demo and I don't know
how deep this one goes but it seemed
relatively interesting hello if you can
hear this I need your help
I'm trapped I think I died I I can't
feel anything I'm afraid you need to
survive hide in the shadows he can't see
you in the dark play his little game and
I promise you I will help you escape
press the space key so I know you
understand well then why do you need my
help okay
oh [ __ ] hello you're gonna give him
[Music]
okay I wasn't ready for that I didn't
know that that's what that would do
ah you got me you got me good I will
admit to you that you got me all right
let's try that again
well okay thanks babe
see you love you good night I wish you
would have told me that just marginally
sooner okay so this seems pretty
standard five nights at freddys fair hey
I see frisk
so I can only imagine that I'm supposed
to uh oh they do really frisky okay I
imagine I'm supposed to turn off the
power when they're here if they do why
would you do that what this happened
wait what what just happened is there
any way to skip this call no oh oh okay
so we're getting back into it I didn't
know about this over here that that
seems like something that I should have
known about but I didn't even know that
I was go ahead oh okay well then I saw
you chica how are you doing can you not
kill well [ __ ] I'm just guessing that
they would be at my door if they were
gonna kill me right right
right right okay I'm an attorney
I don't know what I'm doing I hope I'm
doing right am i I don't know you just
you don't trust that I dress the noises
what does it noises mean I don't know I
don't that bad is it good is that is
that good is that bad I don't know no no
no their reason for that is okay you're
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] just told
everybody okay so that that dude that
was the thing he did appear there I'd be
wasn't helpful [ __ ] okay we're alive
maybe I say may because honestly I have
no idea
we're alive oh how are you okay standard
five nights at freddys fair pretty basic
[ __ ] going on here just like my basic
[ __ ] this being scared by it one hour
left
what are the odds that I'm gonna die of
right now in the last hour huh pretty
high oh [ __ ] don't trust that
what I don't trust it don't trust any
laughing Oh trust no giggles in the
darkness in the darkness in the darkness
Oh tonight I don't trust [ __ ] you are
all gonna be the death of me
come on dingdong dingdong already come
on it's been so time for dingdong come
on a blade for dingdong oh clock oh [ __ ]
I'm late for dingdong there we go now
that is the thing dong of which I know
Oh God the tasty treat it's Halloween
get the keys oh don't mind me
excuse my I don't know I'm gathering
these button mmm finger lookin good
oh hey were you gonna eat this up
thanks man I'm real slow green Freddie
okay um ah you [ __ ]
I'm going to make this quick because of
the master is approaching he is the one
who is controlling them I am beginning
to remember who I was I can see the
wires the the heads it it hurts so bad
I think I had a family anyway keep it up
thanks for the encouragement thank you
[Music]
well I turned out the lights I put it
back in the market I just keep up the
good freaky work touching all these
animatronics like that is that we are
accusing me of what did I die so quickly
saw some homeless guy I thought that
means what do I do if I see someone what
is it oh [ __ ] okay what does it matter
if I did or not am I supposed to do
something about him what am i support
you expect me to do
hey hey I don't think there's any point
to me actually check in the other box
get back in your box we don't want your
kind around here
I think chicas gone for the night I
think that's what he was talking about
putting the big yellow one back in the
box
I don't know what else to do then
because I am at a bit of a curve Farkle
[Applause]
I'm alive where the skin of my teeth
don't trust the laughing I don't just
the laughing we've worked anyway got you
don't trust [ __ ] I've got you oh I see
you what the [ __ ] was that what the way
why was foxy there wait oh hi hi
detective problem I think I think
problem rob prob problem
what oh no it's not that this okay Rob
blob think I'm supposed to keep an eye
on you cuz that's how I know foxy works
I think that that camera there is the
one closest to me so if they're there
I'm in a bit of duel [ __ ] oh [ __ ] foxy
where'd you go
we're oh I see you back there that's
right yeah you get back
unless you're closer to man then I don't
like it oh this is so much giggling this
is so much totaling I don't I don't like
that chortles I swear these last two
hours last longer than the other ones
I think the pre-emptive thing the
preemptively putting this out is good
seems to be working and foxy seems to be
back in his hidey-hole
so that's nice it's a lot of clanking
loud clang no no foxy no come on now
foxy you know better you know better you
get back in your hidey-hole
don't Clank me oh oh here we go more
muffins
give me the muffins put muffin in me I
want it
muffin me I am the muffin man I've come
to take you my friends I can't escape
apparently muffins are there no muffins
for me that was not a muffin that looked
like a giant turd I don't know that's a
penis but I'm picking it up got it okay
I am a little bit suspicious as to what
I'm supposed to be doing here oh that is
huge okay big chica okay did I miss
something
was that supposed to be the last thing I
was supposed to get because I think I
might have goofed it a little bit oh why
does that what is that oh those are too
big those are too big those are way too
big it what am i tiny just a tiny itty
bitty little Freddy okay so I think I
need to find another piece of the chica
puzzle I think that's what it's
suggesting here
so if I just find the last piece oh here
this
wah and that's the end of the demo and I
get a cookie for all that alright so
that was not bad not bad okay and we're
just gonna hard crash okay that was not
bad not bad at all and that was not bad
for three five nights at Freddy's fan
games the middle one was obviously bad
but it was made to be bad but it was
hilariously bad I laughed a lot and that
gives it some enjoyment out of it so
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you got other cool games that you
want me to play or other cool stuff that
you want me to do let me know down in
the comments below thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]